[David Evans, Professor, CS101] Welcome to the first "Office Hours" for CS101.
[Peter Chapman, Assistant Instructor, CS101] I'm here with Peter Chapman, the assistant for the class.
You've been seeing Peter a lot online, you may not have seen him in person until now.
We want to thank you all for all the questions you've been posting in the forums,
and voting on the popular questions. And we will get started answering them now.
>> Okay, so our first question is from user Mortazavi from Iran--and he asks--
He liked Sergey Brin's presence in the class at the beginning, his guest appearance,
and he wants to know if that will be repeated later on?
>>Well, I liked having Sergey in the class as well--Sergey is quite a busy person,
he's running a company that you may have heard of
that has hundreds of millions of people
wanting their queries responded to everyday--
so he doesn't have a lot of time to help us out with a class.
There will be at least one more appearance of Sergey somewhere later in the course.
I won't tell you where exactly now.
We will have lots of appearances from other people that are experts in search engines,
as well as other areas of computing, and those will be scattered throughout the units--
as well as we will especially focus on that--
putting computing in a broader context in the last unit,
and we'll have lots of interviews with interesting people in that unit.